welcome to this video playing brewing
player ping brewing flam this is what do
I have one out of two ok ok I guess what
do we get him the bank oh yeah it's a
still an amazingly popular opening I
guess people have not yet come to
realize that it's very difficult to get
sufficient compensation in the main line
but they're in blitz chess it's probably
still ok to play it and tournament chess
I would really advise not to but in
blitz many things can be done that's
simply the relatively simple way that
black can play is sometimes just
valuable in blitz chess like definitely
doesn't have enough compensation in this
line this is very clear but as mentioned
yeah like has simple moves so that he
can play and sometimes he can muddy the
waters tremendously with e6 and whatever
so it is some probably playable in a in
a practical blitz game but in tournament
chess I really have my doubts now
yeah let's see the bed basically the
only play that black hairs is something
with e6 some kind of some kind of
complications 22 to start them okay b3 I
can't even play b3 here right c4 before
yes no reason not to i think when i get
to stabilize the queenside with 843
rugby 195 this is really just a pawn
like has absolutely nothing for it this
is the the big problem with this a
four-line white has taken I don't know
why 40 years to realize that you can get
this get this started so early and I
don't believe in it absolutely not
especially in longer time controls
okay so Ruby one is the standard
prophylaxis getting out of the long
diagonal the next thing that would be
excellent if I get in okay so he wants
to play mm yeah c4 I can't go 92 the
only question is does he have something
weird on them on the long diagonal 95f
why it could be loose could be a bit
loose Bishop g5 see form and take
strings 92 to see four would be nice be
nice to get in but i'm not sure about it
it looks kind of night if I've ever
looks kind of loose but I cannot really
believe that he has some tactic here
what I had that I don't believe I said
again a tactic 94 Queen look a six
okay come on show me if it works then
all the all the power to you nothing
that I can do here he has to play now
okay six now not be five and then d 6 is
collapsing hmm yeah maybe you can
somehow play that do it take first
probably not might be five yeah of
course the long diagonal yeah there's
always some kind of trickery
Jim I know what is doing a push-up f8
now maybe it's not what you want to do
at how exactly are you covering these
six queen bee eight also looks ugly hmm
you don't know yeah this is more fun
okay I don't release I don't really know
if I can keep the fire probably not here
I have to have to take him and then get
the King King out of this yeah of course
he can get this in but it is by now not
that much of a problem I think because
light on b5 or this is nicely positioned
get it to e5 and I guess I guess Bishop
f4 I can complete development now to
afford to be true maybe bishop be too
long diagonal he can go d 4 but again
this gives me see for so night yeah just
just for the endgame trade everything ok
let's let's go for that
an idea form is this is there some trick
or not f3 this night g5
he wants to go to g5 anyway maybe I am
let's just let's just take the square
way see what is doing next a
prophylactic move okay so he's covering
covering this maybe 92 is also possible
the ship see one or I don't see a tactic
against that one it looks a little bit
shaky but I don't see a tactic relief
9f to like Queen f2 right not going to
work
I can get rid getting rid of if the four
night then things start to clear up
quite a lot but not so not so clear if I
manage that takes takes I could have
taken c5 ok that's a good prophylactic
move though takes takes 95 is ok
so time warning do I take now I don't
know and then then on c5 maybe this is
the simplest way to do it can take be
three maybe rook f2s cell is a threat
maybe really is
check check check check check huh yeah
okay but I was ahead had more time lag
resigned I would have made that who game
game yeah this is what sometimes happens
in those in those positions when you
black really doesn't have enough yet
sets that's kind of clear but it still
is tricky it's kind of twisting and
turning and trying to try to make your
life difficult there is still some
activity the compass of course I mean
this is just without any any fuss plus
1.7 yeah so against the comp you would
lose this position like with like in a
breeze with with black but playing it
with wide over the board with limited
time it's not so easy Bishop f4 is given
by the comp but this is just as good now
it wants to play Bishop f4 and yeah
maybe maybe just piling up on that I was
thinking that taking should be kind of
simple but it wasn't really it that is
strong I am it really is i mean this is
probably not going to be enough right it
looks this still looks scarier to a
human players somehow a little bit at
least g5 and f3 according to stock fish
okay so i gave up a little bit here with
this until he could have gettin in c4 or
not c4 I but okay i can i can i can
sacrifice he actually very complicated
how does hard to tell he played this and
went for this pin and now we're in like
+1 territory troia i had doubts about
that move but okay you have to play it
sometime yeah this this is what the
engine is recommending but i probably he
really has no tricks IAM or thinking
maybe else with this but the computer is
just merciless it wants to take here
check go for this and then return the
exchange yeah okay that's some point to
that this in fact looks great iam this
looks kind of great but very difficult
for a human to play and age for now d
forgives black some compensation it's
not like it's straight win anymore
well kept like a sec tortilla it's just
a choice it's not it's not hitting the
nail on the head right I hear that was
strong now ok I have to be realistic
Bishop see one looks good trading a
piece and round TM in winning position
territory again yeah okay I hear mother
was simply I should have taken in Fling
Queen echeck getting the porn i would
have been very easy yeah okay so what is
them thing to remember here is that if
you are wide and you need a good you
need a line against the banco 12 a four
is excellent you have to be ready to
play a little bit of a prophylactically
am after that to snuff out flex play but
i think you will manage and what would
be better yeah mehbeh did some still
tricky in blitz but in longer time
control games i think white is in really
good shape okay well thanks for watching